fidélité aujourd'hui on se penche sur la
folie sondagière avec un peu de
pédagogie pour commencer selon quelle
méthode les sondages sont ils réalisent
et c6 ou
première étape pour fabriquer un sondage
politique la consultation les sondeurs
interroge un échantillon représentatif
de français choisis selon plusieurs
critères la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle le genre le niveau
de diplôme ou encore la région il faut
au moins 1000 personnes pour faire un
échantillon fiable et plus il ya de
monde plus le sondage sera précis mais
cela ne garantit pas forcément la
représentation de la population
française et pour être au plus proche
dans les instituts comme ici à l'ifop on
fait donc ce que l'on appelle un
redressement bon sur la base de données
objectives et réels c'est-à-dire les
comportements électoraux passés on peut
corriger l'échantillon pour qu'il ne
branche pas trop d'un côté ou de l'autre
ça nous permet de gagner en précision
dans les résultats qu'on va rendre donc
c'est pas une distorsion des résultats
c'est pas une espèce de boîte noire dont
on ne sait pas trop ce qui se passe
c'est une correction une correction
souvent très minime pour être sûr que
quand on vous dit que 60 % des français
estiment que et bien c'est pas 59 ou 61
autre enjeu pour les sondeurs que faire
des indécis ceux qui ne sont pas sûrs
d'aller voter tous les instituts vont
avoir un moyen de pondérer en quelque
sorte la vie des gens en fonction leur
statique d'aller voter
certains ne vont garder que les gens
certains d'aller voter tout simplement
est complètement évacué des autres voilà
certains ont affecté des pondérations
des différences de méthodes assumé par
les sondeurs mais de plus en plus
critiquée notamment par les partis
extrêmes qui se disent pénalisés car les
indécis représentent une bonne partie de
leur électorat
les sondages fausse-t-il cette campagne
présidentielle voilà thème de notre
débat je vous présente mes invités
brigitte d'haïti bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes positif professeur de sciences
politiques à l'université paris 1 jean
garrigues bonsoir il historien
professeur à l'université d'orléans vous
êtes le présent du comité d'histoire
parlementaire et politique avec nous en
visioconférence jean daniel lévy qui est
le directeur délégué d'harris
interactive france bonsoir jean daniel
giny merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation matthieu croissandeau
évidemment il rester à mes côtés
peut-être un un constat on parle
beaucoup de frénésie sondagière depuis
quelques semaines est ce que vous avez
ce sentiment brigitte katie pour
commencer qui a beaucoup plus de
sondages que d'habitude à six mois dans
un premier tour
j'ai pas fait le calcul oui mais j'ai
l'impression effectivement mais un peu
comme tout le monde qu'il ya une
frénésie sondagière parce qu'il ya une
incertitude complète sur la
présidentielle que ça commence très tôt
du coup et kia dévoile à des tas de on
voit bien d'état stratégies possibles
des candidats qui peut-être commande des
sondages où j'étais pas des partis qui
sont très inquiet sur la suite de la
suite de nos affaires donc mais rien
d'autre que cette question est ce que
c'est parce que la nature un peu peur du
vide que yahoo n'y a pas eu de
cristallisation encore dans certains
partis que on se repose à ce point sur
les sondages jean garrigues je crois
qu'à c'est assez clairement on a
l'impression en tout cas en ce moment
que les sondages fonctionne un peu comme
un substitut de des carences partisane
vers que les partis ont du mal à
sélectionner leur candidat on l'a bien
vu alors les verts finalement ont réussi
leur leur primaire et ça a bien
fonctionné on voit bien que dans un des
grands partis traditionnels les
républicains bien les problèmes
primaire congrès on sait pas très bien
donc xavier bertrand s'est engouffré
juste en cette brèche sondagière je
dirais pour ce pour se positionner et
puis du côté du parti socialiste là
aussi on veut pas dire que la sélection
c'est ça soit ça soit très bien passé et
là aussi on voit bien que les sondages
pourrait aussi procédé à une sorte de
filtrage à gauche peut-être même entre
la candidate socialiste et deux
candidats écologistes bon ça je
j'anticipe un mais mais on voit bien en
tout cas que ça ça dit quelque chose de
la carence en tout cas des difficultés
des partis ça c'est sûr jean daniel lévy
je sais pas si vous avez les chiffres
mais est ce que oui ou non vous avez
vous le sentiment de l'intérieur que
l'on commande plus de sondages qu'il ya
cinq ans en 2016 ou même s'ils remontent
loin 2011
plus de 100h publié visiblement oui les
premiers décomptes et complète refait
montre qu'il y a plus de temps kate qui
sont qui sont à réaliser je pense qu'il
ya deux explications principales la
première c'est qu'il devient de plus en
plus facile d'être techniquement ou de
réaliser des sondages et on peut même
les réaliser dans des temps qui sont
bien plus resserrée aujourd'hui qu'on
peut le faire il ya encore de cela qu'il
ya quelques années le deuxième aspect
effectivement il ya une demande il ya
une demande de la part notamment de
médias non seulement de commande de
sondages mais également de l'analyse des
sondages et dans les périodes qui ce
n'est pas la certitude qu'on peut le
voir parmi les différents candidats
potentiels elles sont confidentielles
certains sont même pas encore déclaré
l'idée de savoir comment se structure
aujourd'hui les représentations et pour
dire les choses très clairement il ya
d'émergence aujourd'hui et eric zemmour
dans le débat public qui constituent un
cinquième inégalé sous la vème
république et qui suscite indéniablement
non seulement à l'inter en matière de
sondages mais également un intérêt très
fort d'un point de vue médiatique oui
mais alors
la frénésie elle est chiffrée mais elle
est aussi dans notre processus
d'interprétation à nous journalistes
observateurs et politiques et
d'utilisation parfois des sondages qui
j'éprouve parfois peut-être un peu plus
importante que l'importance qu'on peut
accorder aux sondages on est dans un
moment où on a six mois l'élection
présidentielle je pense que personne a
la prétention de dresser la photographie
teckel se fera le cas du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et même on
peut parler de frénésie de son âge qu'on
va regarder la totalité des sondages qui
sont plus liés la plupart ne sont pas
liés ni à l'élection présidentielle ni
même aux intentions de vote à proprement
parler mais il ya de très nombreuses
enquêtes qui visent à regarder est ce
que peut être le coeur de la société
française où on appelle une très grosse
enquête auprès de 10000 personnes pour
challenges à la fin de l'été et qui a eu
un arrêt zone enfin trouvé une résonance
un peu moins importante mais que des
intentions de vote là il ya vraiment
notre responsabilité collective joindre
aux gens vont aussi à une enquête
publiée par nos confrères du monde qui
sont allés à la rencontre de des
français sur le terrain à la base du
métier c'est le reportage quand même ne
l'oublions jamais dans une centaine de
villages sans reporter sans
photoreporter enfin voila c c'est aussi
ça un moyen de d'évaluer l'état du pays
et disent d'ailleurs dans le dossier du
monde qu'il reconnaisse pas tout à fait
dans la france qu'ils ont rencontrées
sur le terrain celle des sondages oui
c'est souvent le cas il ya une frénésie
de sondages comme le disait journée les
lie c'est un couple infernal quand même
un les sondeurs les médias
il commande des sondages parce qu'on a
parfois soit du mal à analyser les
situations politiques soit parce que ça
va faire le buzz il faut aussi se parler
franchement et d'une certaine façon on
pousse en plus au crime parce qu'un
sondage qui n'est pas spectaculaire
n'intéressera pas les médias donc il
faut se dire les choses et un sondage
qui montre une progression beaucoup plus
forts de tel ou tel candidat sera
abondamment commentée parfois au
détriment des sondages maison commandé
par les propres journaux bref une espèce
de course à l'échalote
dans ce couple sondeurs médias il faut
pas évidemment les sondages sont utiles
jeu mais est ce qu'il en a besoin
d'autant pas si sûr d'autant que est ce
que vraiment à trois quatre jours
d'intervalle il ya des mouvements
d'opinion tels que ça permet de donner
une photographie très différentes d'une
semaine à l'autre de d'un potentiel
premier tour en fonction des potentiels
candidats moi ça me paraît sans doute un
peu exagéré
après ce que disent les gens et la
garrigue est aussi assez juste les
parties sont tellement faibles qu'ils se
tournent même vers les sondages rendez
vous compte que les républicains willam
un grand parti quel a été le premier
réflexe de christian jacob pour désigner
le candidat à la primaire c'est à dire
on va demander un sondeur
avec la hauteur pour savoir qui est le
plus populaire mais il ya il ya dix ans
tout le monde se serait arraché les
cheveux ségolène royal était qualifiée
de candidate des sondages par les
socialistes de l'époque alors c'était
sur l'autre bord de gic et musées c'est
quand même pas les sondages qui vont
désigner notre candidat et on en est on
en est là aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il
ya sept des dvd valorisation des partis
qui ne savent plus sélectionner leur
candidat qui ne savent plus sur quel
idée qui sont obligés de se d'interroger
l'opinion publique pour savoir mais
quelles valeurs sont importantes pour
vous et quelles personnalités peuvent le
mieux représenté si on fait un peu de
pédagogie des descendants vrai qu'on
parle de la de la marge d'erreur
brigitte d'haïti par exemple si on prend
le trio marine le pen eric zemmour et
xavier bertrand ou valérie pécresse je
veux dire d'ailleurs xavier bertrand
parce que c'est celui qui reste malgré
tout le plus haut est ce que on peut les
classer
1 2 3 2 3 1 voyez ce que je veux dire de
1,3 en feront passer ensemble la marge
d'erreur simplement prenant le haut de
la fourchette en bas de la fourchette
pour les autres non je crois pas qu'on
puisse lesquels des classes et je pense
qu'on dit alors on est dans la marge
d'erreur mais vous savez que la marge
d'erreur théoriquement ce serait quelque
chose de valide si on était dans des
sondages aléatoires et qu'on pouvait
avoir une approche probabiliste donc ça
n'est pas le cas mais disons que
là on vraisemblablement on peut pas là
ce qu'on est en train de faire c'est pas
de tester l'opinion en réalité c'est
qu'on est en train de chercher les
candidats en fait et donc et les
torsions la démocratie
de ce point de vue alors par exemple si
on prend 1981 mitterrand et déclarer
candidat alors que rocard apparaît comme
un meilleur candidat dans les sondages
donc l'appareil du parti est
suffisamment fort pour dire c'est
mitterrand c'est le chef du parti y
vivent à ségolène royal tout à l'heure
vous le rappeliez ségolène royal elle et
elle s'appuie quand même beaucoup sur
les sondages contre l'appareil déjà et
on a l'impression aujourd'hui que les
sons les sondages ça va en fait à
générer des éligibles et donc il ya une
espèce de filtres que je crois que ces
gens gardent qui le disait tout à
l'heure espèce de deux filtres qui en
joker et qui donne un rôle le sondage
absolument incroyable dans une situation
d'incertitude de fragmentation des
parties les primaires ont joué leur jeu
on a l'impression maintenant si vous
voulez de plus en plus l'élection de
d'emmanuel macrolane année on a
l'impression que tout est possible et
donc les sondages jouent leur partition
tout le monde les médias certainement
signe à ma fille les parties se rendent
compte que non oui les médias jouent
leur partition et évidemment je reviens
sur cette histoire de marge d'erreur
jean daniel lévy quand on place eric
zemmour pour la première fois devant
marine le pen est ce que finalement je
reprends ma question je suis un peu déçu
est ce que il s'agit de placer marine le
pen dans le bas de sa fourchette la
marge d'erreur est à eric zemmour dans
le haut de sa fourchette voyez très bien
ce que je veux dire et je vois très bien
ce que voulait dire en fait les termes
place est certain que je ne comprends
pas en tout cas je comprends ce que
voulait dire mais ça ne correspond pas à
notre pratique il né il ya parfois des
grands mystères sur comme que font les
sondeurs que se passe-t-il d'ailleurs à
la boîte noire à des différents
instituts de sondage ce que l'on fait
déjà est un travail rigoureux réalisé de
l'apartheid interactive depuis
si le tronc pas avril dernier toutes les
semaines pour challenges avec exactement
la même méthodologie c'est à dire quoi
pas adaptés en fonction la semaine une
méthodologie à une méthodologie b pour
soi faire du buzz soit pour créer un
événement
tous les travaux sont validés par la
commission nationale pour lesquels remet
systématiquement avant même la
publication la manière dont nous avons
été amenés à travailler l'échantillon et
les calculs de ce qu'on appelle le
redressement le redressement que celle
de pointage et il s'agit de faire en
sorte que l'échantillon de départ
correspondent à l'ensemble de la
population est évidemment quand on
interroge 1000 ou 2000 personnes s'est
jamais tout à fait parfait donc à un
correctif qui était un correctif
statistiques mais qui n'est pas un
correctif politique ou pas un correctif
éditorial c'est vrai que lorsque les
enquêtes été réalisé par téléphone on
avait une difficulté et
la tentation du média est le premier à
l'annoncer quand on est à ce point avec
trois 3 candidats touche tous ces
éléments mais quelle est la
responsabilité dans ce cas là c'est de
se dire on a sur 100 personnes
interrogées 17 qui nous ont déclaré
qu'ils avaient l'intention de voter eric
zemmour et oullins à 15 qui déclarent
qu'ils ont l'intention de voter pour
marine le pen donc soit on dit bah ça
pose un problème et donc doit ce cas là
bas on va raconter n'importe quoi et et
changer les chiffres à la main soit on
dit on a exactement ce qui ressort de la
machine de notre enquête dans un
processus encore une fois qui est un
processus qui a réalisé enquête après
enquête toutes les semaines et c'était
je crois cette enquête là la 15e ou 16e
enquête rue nous ils ont été amenés à
réaliser d'une progression est ce que
cela veut dire que demain on a la
certitude qu eric zemmour sera présent
au 2e tour la réponse est non assurément
non et je les avais dire que marine le
pen ou que éventuellement xavier
bertrand est disqualifié la réponse est
non assuré mal an et si vous regardez je
ne parle pas uniquement des chiffres
mais également les lettres qui
accompagne chacune des intentions de
vote réalisé par harris interactive vous
verrez néo pro cherche pas être dans le
dans les aspects spectaculaires
répondre à cette question j'en ai élevé
mais hélas on retombe dans garrigue sur
la responsabilité des commentateurs qui
est la façon de tirer une leçon
politique qui peut sembler effectivement
une projection d'haddad d'une
photographie à l'instant t bien souvent
ce qui s'est passé dans les critiques
qu'on a pu formuler sur sur les sondages
et les erreurs qui ont été commises vous
dire côté produite plus que commises par
par les sondages au fond c'est est ses
erreurs imputées en réalité étaient
imputés en réalité 2 v être imputée aux
commentateurs en réalité puisque on sait
bien que les sondages sont instantanés
qui vaut ce qu'il vaut deux une opinion
à un moment donné que d'abord c'est leur
dynamique qui est intéressante c'est
d'abord et avant tout la dynamique des
sondages qui est intéressante en tout
cas pour une élection présidentielle
mais je crois que sur tous les sujets
pour voir évoluer justement sur le long
terme au moins sur le moyen terme une
opinion une société mais c'est très
souvent la manière dont vont être
interprétés moi je les ai vues à propos
de ce sont d'un premier sondage qui
mettait eczéma ou devant marine le pen
où il ya eu des extrapolations des
commentateurs qui était totalement en
dehors de du raisonnable en réalité est
qui et qui ne ne relevait pas justement
de d'un exercice démocratique
d'information de la population il ya une
co responsabilité des journalistes et
des politiques aussi des politiques
aussi bien sûr qui en joue de toute
manière d'en parler de terreur de xavier
bertrand la stratégie de xavier bertrand
pour
s'imposer comme le candidat des
républicains c'est une stratégie qui est
totalement appuyé sur les sondages il ya
aussi évidemment sa personnalité son son
programme son lien avec les territoires
tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est
extrêmement appuyé sur les sondages
c'est d'ailleurs quelque chose de
complètement nouveau à droite parce que
parce que la droite on s'imposait
d'abord parce qu'on prenait le parti
jacques chirac en 76 le rpr
nicolas sarkozy en 2004 qui prend l'ump
qui avait été créée par alain juppé donc
on prend le parti et on s'impose dans sa
famille politique la com aucun n'est
capable de s'imposer on essaie par le
truchement des sondages d'imposer
justement leadership c'est assez
intéressant ce qui se passe en ce moment
alors on va rappeler la l'extrême
prudence à six mois d'un premier tour
d'une élection présidentielle et pour ça
hein un coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur
1995 en est en janvier voilà ce que nous
disent les sondages edouard balladur
devant à 29% lionel jospin à 24% jacques
chirac à 16% seulement est le résultat
du premier tour de la présidentielle
lionel jospin à 23,3 jacques chirac qui
grimpe à 20 8 edouard balladur qui sera
éliminé alors que c'était l'ultra favori
des sondages et même de la presse en ce
début d'année 95 je continue avec 2002
évidemment comprendre ne pas se souvenir
de 2002 là je vous propose une moyenne
des douze derniers sondages publiés donc
on est plus proche du premier tour
jacques chirac à 20 lionel jospin 18
jean marie le pen seulement à 12 7% et
finalement il passera de peu mais il
passera devant lionel jospin évidemment
s'en souvient avec 16,9 contre 16,2
seulement au candidat socialiste et puis
beaucoup plus près de nous les élections
régionales de cette année intentions de
vote au premier tour là on est en juin
de cette année le rassemblement national
qui est donnée en tête dans six régions
sur treize donc là on est proche de vote
et des résultats du premier tour
finalement le mouvement de marine le pen
ne sera en tête que en région paca et ne
remportera pas de région matthieu
croissandeau qu'est ce qui peut faire
mentir un sondage si là aussi on regarde
un peu dans le rétro essayer de regarder
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient pu faire entre
un sondage et c'était quoi les recettes
et en fait ces trois éléments il ya
d'abord une dynamique de campagne
l'exemple le plus proche c'est jean luc
mélenchon 2010 est entre le début et la
fin de sa campagne jean luc mélenchon
double quasiment son score son discours
il a à l'époque abandonné le bruit et la
fureur ces meetings vous souvenez il
fait beaucoup de meetings en plein air
il mobilise beaucoup sur numérique son
humour lors des débats son
positionnement la force du peuple un
petit écho à la force tranquille sa
cible unique le parti socialiste pour
pour le siphonner vous fait que en gros
il déroule une campagne sans trou d'air
il en avait connu en 2012 en 2012
c'était plutôt l'inversé les sondages
donnaient plus haut et du coup il finit
à 600 mille voix du second tour de 600
mille voix qu'ils sont en travers de la
gorge ça c'est la dynamique de deuxième
élément c'est le coup de pouce du destin
alors là je vais trouver un autre
exemple c'est françois hollande pourquoi
françois hollande parce qu'en décembre
2010 il est un candidat auquel personne
ne croit il est au plus bas dans les
sondages ses camarades socialistes y ont
toujours un peu cruel entre le surnomme
monsieur 3% lui fait le job il fait
qu'ils continuent à faire campagne avec
apnée dac avec abnégation pardon sa
théorie c'est le trou de souris à
françois hollande c'est toujours au
dernier moment si un trou de souris hop
je me faufile qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est
pas un trou de souris mais
voilà le coup du destin qui fait chuter
l'archi favori des sondages dominique
strauss kahn et du coup désigné par le
ps qu'il connaît comme sa poche face à
martine aubry et françois hollande
monsieur 3% devient président et puis le
troisième le troisième facteur que j'ai
vu aucun récemment c'est une sorte d'
effet repoussoir et là c'est l'exemple
françois bayrou 2007 le centriste à
l'époque les candidats à la
présidentielle pour la deuxième fois il
est crédité de 8% des voix quand il se
déclare candidat et puis il va
bénéficier d'une image rassurante au
fond et attirer à lui tout un nombre
d'électeurs qui sont socialistes ou
gauche qui sont un peu effrayé un peu
épouvanté par la candidose la
candidature de ségolène royal parlant à
qui on attribue mille et une gaffe vous
souvenez de cette campagne mais
bizarroïdes et du coup cet effet
repoussoir fait que ça va se traduire de
façon politique il ya des cimes temps
qui commence à l'appeler pour lui les
gracques ya michel rocard jeu patients
s'en souvient rejoint par bernard claude
allègre qui dit il faudrait que l'udf ça
s'appelait comme ça à l'époque et le ps
se mettre d'accord bref cet accord
n'aura jamais lieu mais françois bayrou
qui avait démarré à 8 % fini à 18 57% et
puis quand vous êtes vert lime et vous
avez les trois vous avez une dynamique
de campagne vous avez un coup de pouce
du destin qu'on pourrait appeler
françois hollande empêché de se
représenter ou françois fillon enfin
dans la dernière campagne pris dans une
affaire puis vous avez un effet
repoussoir avec une candidature de
gauche à l'époque parce que on draguait
la gauche benoît hamon qui était pas
forcément n'était pas forcément jugé
très attractive pour un nombre grand
nombre de lecteurs et vous avez résultat
c'est emmanuel macron en 2017 voilà jean
daniel lévy vous disiez tout à l'heure
que c'était que c'était sans précédent
le phénomène emo en quoi c'est sans
précédent pour vous
c'est amp parce que non seulement papier
une progression très forte d'un candidat
qui sort pas du tout du sérail et quand
on voit qu'il commence me campagne à 7
pour son état il est mesuré entre 16 et
17% selon les différents instituts de
sondages et que cette progression qui
s'effectue en sensiblement un mois n'a
jamais été vus depuis que des sondages
soient réalisés sous la vème répliquer
plus le deuxième aspect c'est qu'il a
quasiment siphonner un électorat qui est
issu de la droite qui initialement
tourné son regard vert marine de panis
qui au final à l'heure actuelle lorgne
plutôt du côté d'eric zemmour en se
disant que c'est le candidat à l'heure
actuelle qui leur convient le mieux
parce qu'il apparaît comme étant ici la
droite parce qu'il apparaît comme étant
cohérent et puis parce qu'il apparaît
comme étant un des seuls à utiliser le
terme islam dans les cas de ces
différentes prises de parole mais c'est
surtout un la rapidité de progression
dans les enquêtes d'opinion et 2 la
manière dont ce sculpture son électorat
quasiment au détriment d'un seul autre
électorat mathieu quazar par exemple que
des références tout à l'heure à françois
bayrou il a effectivement progressé dans
un premier temps sur
auprès d'un électorat socialisant qui
craignaient
ségolène royal mais qui a également en
fin de campagne réussi à récupérer une
partie de l'électorat de nicolas sarkozy
ce qui se passe à l'heure actuelle avec
eric zemmour à ce titre-là y apparaît
comme étant singulier mais pour autant
brigitte bien haïti l'opinion faire là
on est un peu dans notre eau notre
mécanique oui les tic au médiatique a
quand même soyons ayant un peu de recul
sur nous mêmes
l'opinion ne s'est pas cristallisées
encore il ya une large part des français
qui n'ont pas fait leur choix tout à
fait et ça les sondeurs le savent bien
parce qu'il ya plein de sons
d'ajustement qui essaye de voir quand
est-ce que kankan fêtons nos choix est
ce que c'est une semaine un jour dans le
dans l'isoloir ou est ce que c'est de
tout temps on est ce qu'on a vraiment ça
de très près ce que c'est de plus en
plus tard aussi que voilà ça c'est une
question d'ailleurs se pose aussi les
sens bien mais ce qu'on voit c'est que
il n'ya pas même
disons dans les tous les réponses au
sondage sur cette question là il ya
entre 40 et 70 % des gens qui disent je
j'ai mon opinion voilà j'ai mon opinion
la campagne par exemple la dynamique de
campagne la période pour une joue pas
mais ce qui veut dire aussi que pour les
autres on sait pas trop ce qui joue en
réalité et quand on est en train de
tester ici on est six mois avant
l'élection si je m'abuse et donc six
mois avant il ya au moins 60 ou 50 % des
gens si on si on en croit les sondages
qui n'ont pas fait qu'ils n'ont pas
encore choisi quand on dit par exemple
qui récuse et moi à siphonner un
électeur il a rien siphonner du tout il
n'est pas encore de vol n'est même pas
candidat donc il n'a rien si ce n'est
dans les ceux qui répondent dans les
sondages disent qu'ils auraient voté
marine le pen il faudrait voir ça de
plus près parce que là on va sur des
échantillons extrêmement réduits et
quand même on n'est plus dans les 1000
personnes on commence à faire des truies
sur des toutes petites populations donc
il a pas siphonné on n'en sait rien ce
qu'il ya c'est qu'il est il devient
éligible et ça c'est la responsabilité
c'est il imite dans le dans le la liste
des gens les commentateurs c'est quand
même faut reconnaître que celle base
effectivement ça ça vient de nulle part
et c'est ça rappelle un peu la sphère
coluche dans un autre dans un autre
genre qui avait été justement canaliser
à temps par le parti socialiste qui
avait dit suffit là c'est nous qui
tenons sentant un petit peu que ça
siphonnaient aussi pour le cool les
risques en tout cas qu'il anticipait des
risques de siphonnage il avait réussi à
dire et je crois qu'il ya eu des menaces
aussi sur coluche et a dit qu'il avait
été un petit peu meilleure dehors là bon
ben voilà il était en train de ce qui
est en train de se passer c'est une
espèce là il ya un aspect but moi je
suis désolé je pense mais ce fut quand
même à la faire c'est nous on ne sait
pas de ça ça met du coup maintenant il
va devenir indélogeable ses salles au
risque alors faisons infos que je
t'assure qui avaient été les vôtres asie
et ensuite j'en ai dit pourquoi pour
pouvoir les prononcer moi je voudrais
rebondir là dessus de ce que je pensais
tout à fait c'est tout à fait vrai
pendant six mois on entendu au peut-être
même plus une petite musique un peu de
découragement de la part des médias et
de la classe politique
par rapport à un affrontement de second
tour pour lequel tout était joué on nous
disait ça sera macron comme contre
marine le pen sous-entendu olalala barbe
encore eu et j'ai l'impression que la
l'émergence de zemmour est apparu quand
même pour une bénédiction pour un
certain nombre de médias pas tous mais
qui a eu quand même
aussi parce que son discours est
disruptif et évoque d'ailleurs là le
côté je dirais extérieur qui était le
discours d' emmanuel macron lui-même en
2017 sur des terrains très différents
mais parce qu'il y avait cette
différence parce qu'avais sept districts
ilité et parce qu'ils cassaient le jeu
compte compte qu'on nous présentait
comme prévu la logique des médias c'est
de dire ah bah et aussi des adversaires
c'est à dire que c'est que c'est quand
même une bénédiction que c'est quelque
chose qu'on attendait avec une sorte de
gourmandise on le voit bien cette
gourmandise elle existe dans la la la la
multitude des d'éditoriaux des
démissions qui sont faites autour de lui
ça ne veut pas dire que le candidat
lui-même n'est pas n'incarne pas quelque
chose quelque chose de fort ça dit aussi
quelque chose beaucoup de la fluidité
aujourd'hui de lectorat de d'un électeur
qui consumériste qui qui peut changer
très vite d'avis aussi qui est hyper
individualiste cercle et les cultures
collective les cultures partisane qui
faisait que mais on restait quelques
fois un dopé office sur tel ou tel vote
tout ça est en train d'exploser donc lui
il s'engouffre là dedans mais macron
l'avait déjà fait en 2010 est finalement
c'était il avait quand même il était
ancien ministre il avait déjà ce serait
un petit peu plus mais mais quelque part
je
sursaute un tout petit peu quand on me
dit zemmour c'est le camp dial
antisystème zemmour c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est dans le système
politico-médiatique depuis minimum une
quinzaine d'années qui a émergé dans
l'émission de laurent ruquier mais
qu'était un journaliste quand même
reconnus qui publiait les oies donc
c'est pas tout à fait quelqu'un qui est
hors du système qui flirtait une
certaine façon leur tel plus en phase
avec l'engagement politique l'agent
daniel lévy sur ce que disait président
d'haïti tout à l'heure sur finalement
c'est une c'est une bulle premiers
éléments de la question et puis deuxième
élément est là c'est moi est-ce que ça a
du sens de
de sonde est à ce point alors que près
d'un français sur deux n'a pas encore
fait son choix je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire une bulle en tant que tel
parce qu'en fait c'est aujourd'hui un
phénomène qui est un phénomène de
société il est présent dans les médias
il de ce quasiment pas mystère qui va
être candidat à la prochaine élection
présidentielle et il se met en route
pour pouvoir avoir des financements un
qg de campagne du personnel autour de
lui des signatures et c'est la bulle
c'est si jamais demain il devait y avoir
un arrêt complet des intentions de vote
en sa faveur et qu' il aurait émergé un
moment particulier par la suite en fait
sans substance et sans véritable force
politique ça je pourrais vous répondre
avec plus de certitudes au cours des
semaines à venir pouvoir ainsi 6 assists
et une bulle éphémère ou pas le deuxième
aspect
il ya toujours deux questions qui se
posent sur les secondes pour les
sondeurs en tout cas pour noir laisse
interactive c1 à quelle fréquence
chansons des deux qu'elles soient les
personnalités qu'on peut être amené à
tester pour avec challenges en cdi dès
le départ qu'on allait faire une enquête
hebdomadaire ce qui est intéressant
c'est que pendant trois-quatre mois
personne n'a repris mais inquiète parce
que personne n'ait trouvé le moindre
intérêt et en considérant que ça
changeait pas du tout et ce à partir du
moment où il ya eu un mouvement il ya eu
un intérêt qui a été suscitée et là je
vous cache pas que la plupart des
journalistes attendent tous les
mercredis le résultat des enquêtes donc
c'est pas c'est pas uniquement le fruit
d'harris interactive on s'est posé la
même question pour eric zemmour qui à
l'époque pour emmanuel macron mais ça
n'a pas fait le même débat à l'époque
des manières macron alors même qu'il
n'était pas candidat on l'avait déjà
testé et il était déjà testé certes à un
niveau qu était moindre certes avec
l'hypothèse où françois hollande à cette
époque là était considéré comme étant
candidat potentiel mais il n'était pas
plus déclaré que ne l'est aujourd'hui et
et risée mots alors même puis l'abbé
comme mi-17 ambre deux pions qui
permettait d'entrevoir le fait qu'il
voulait véritablement aller à la
candidature c'est le cas pour quasiment
tous des responsables politiques et si
j'étais un tout petit peu taquin je vous
dirais conteste aujourd'hui par exemple
emmanuel macron qui à ma connaissance
n'est pas encore candidat l'élection
présidentielle effectivement on prend on
prend la taquinerie sans aucun problème
on va se poser une dernière question
tient là il nous reste une dizaine
minutes dans ce débat est-ce qu'il faut
changer les règles et pour ça j'appelle
alexandre pousse à rejoindre de nouveau
il ya dix ans alexandre les sénateurs
justement essayer de réformer les règles
de publication des sondages pour qu'ils
ne perturbent pas le débat public et
menaces qu'en réalité la loi qui encadre
ces règles de publication des sondages
et bien cette loi elle date de
1977 bientôt 45 ans alors en 2011 il y a
dix ans deux sénateurs l'un de droite
eut portelli l'autre de gauche le
sénateur socialiste jean-pierre sueur
ils déposent une proposition de loi pour
mettre un petit peu plus de transparence
dans ses règles des instituts de sondage
et on va se replonger dans cette réforme
de l'époque avec cette archive de public
sénat regarder
le sénat a introduit aujourd'hui plus de
clarté et de transparence en modernisant
la loi existante inchangé depuis 1977 il
élargit l'encadrement des sondages
électoraux à l'ensemble des sondages de
caractère politique on a beaucoup de
sondages aujourd'hui qui traite des
questions politiques mais qui sont en
dehors du champ de la loi or la
distinction entre les sondages
politiques et les sondages électoraux
est de plus en plus insaisissable
puisqu'on fait aujourd'hui sondages
électoraux quasiment toute l'année et
même les ados n'y a pas d'élection le
sénat a par ailleurs voté d'autres
mesures précisant les conditions de
réalisation des enquêtes d'opinion les
ovales parmi celles ci la publication
des marges d'erreur et du taux de non
réponses et la publication de l'identité
du commanditaire du sondage
voilà pour cette archive qui date du 14
février 2011 alors cette proposition loi
elle est adoptée à l'époque par le sénat
mais elle ne verra pas le jour à ce
moment là car elle n'est pas reprise par
l'assemblée nationale et il faut dire
que le président de la république de
l'époque nicolas sarkozy y est opposé
mais cinq ans plus tard les deux
sénateurs hugues portelli et jean pierre
sueur reviennent à la charge et tente de
faire repasser leur réforme via un
amendement un projet de loi qui modifie
les règles de la présidentielle alors en
2016 et bien on est à la fin du
quinquennat de françois hollande et le
gouvernement socialiste l'aîné lui non
plus pas très chaud pour modifier ses
règles de publication des sondages et le
sénateur hugues portelli n'est pas
surpris par ces réticences de l'exécutif
y gouverne qu'ils soient de gauche ou de
droite à partir du moment où son pouvoir
et non plus du tout envie qu'on
réglemente les sondages
parce qu'ils sont trop liés avec les
instituts ils les font trop vivre avec
leurs moyens gouvernementaux et voire
même illégalement par voie de temps en
temps pour certains deux pour que et
bien on ans de toucher au magot des
instituts de sondage des mots très forts
du duc portelli à l'époque dans ce débat
de 2016 et au final ces deux sénateurs
réussissent à faire voter leurs
amendements par le parlement et donc
depuis 2016 et bien de nouvelles règles
s'imposent aux instituts de sondages ils
doivent indiquer le nom du commanditaire
de chaque sondage
la marge d'erreur le texte intégral des
questions qui ont été posées et puis ils
doivent aussi publier la notice du
sondage c'est un peu la recette de
cuisine ça veut dire que depuis 2016 et
bien tout citoyen peut désormais
connaître la méthode employée le taux de
non réponses les éventuels gratification
qui sont versées aux personnes
interrogées s'il y en a eu et puis
également les critères de redressement
des résultats bruts on a entendu cette
notion dans le sujet de cécile 6 oh ça
veut dire que pour faire un sondage est
bien parfois les résultats bruts sont
modifiés pour que le sondage soit plus
représentatif de la société française
donc voilà comment en quelques années
ces deux sénateurs ont mis un petit peu
plus de transparence dans les règles des
instituts de sondage merci alexandre
ceux ci ne sont persévérance politique
fatigué parce qu' il fallait pas lâcher
jeandel et vie je reviens vers vous ces
règles elle s'applique aujourd'hui on a
un peu le sentiment que
peut-être la machine médiatique et
politique fait comme si ça n'existait
pas pourtant vous vous l'appliquez dans
chacune et dans chaque enquête dans
chaque sondage évidemment on le fond
kung fu l'afrique mais en plus on a
intérêt à l'appliquer parce qu'en fait
on doit maintenant rendre des comptes
systématiquement avant chaque sondage
d'intentions de vote publié à la
commission des sondages sur l'ensemble
du processus tel qu'il a été très bien
décrit tout à l'heure si on permettait
juste un point par rapport à ce qu'ils
ont eue portelli et quelques années et
il faut remettre je pense la partie
économique à sa juste place c'est pas un
magot que touchent les instituts de
sondage du fait des formations
politiques notamment au regard des
enquêtes qui sonne enquête publiée d'une
manière générale dans la plupart des
instituts le volume du chiffre
d'affaires généré s'appuie
essentiellement sur des études marketing
et la partie politique publiée en tout
cas chez harris est inférieure à 1% de
l'ensemble du chiffre d'affaires de
l'ensemble de l'institut donc on a
indéniablement intérêt à voir notre nom
repris parce qu'en fait on engage notre
marque langage notre crédibilité mais
c'est pas un enjeu qui est un enjeu
économique pour nous tels que cela
pouvait être saoul entendre c'est un
enjeu d'image donc un enjeu indirects on
peut quand même dire ses impressions
voilà
le temps file ce qui est bon signe ça
prouve que ce débat est vraiment
passionnant jean garrigues il y avait
aussi dans les propos de du sénateur
portelli une référence à un gouvernement
par les sondages à ce que à ce que les
gouvernements en place comment dès lors
on est en pleine actualité avec le
l'affairé de l'abus de deux sondages par
la présidence sarkozy entre 2007 et 2009
qui vient de qui vient de démarrer mais
ça c'est pas nouveau c est ce qu est-ce
que c'est exponentiel là aussi je ne
sais pas si vous avez
j'ai pas les chiffres mais je suppose
que c'est relativement exponentielle qui
est de plus en plus on voit très bien
que ce rapport avec l'opinion et cette
distance qui s'est créé conduit
justement un versement à aller de plus
en plus recherchés cette opinion qu'on
n'arrive pas finalement à saisir et en
tout cas à rassembler ça c'est une
certitude on n'imagine pas le général de
gaulle gouvernants par les phares les
sondages bien que c'était ça lui était
étranger ça et c'est une île un jeune
héros il avait une idée un dessin pour
la france est il un pays il imposait ce
dessin aux français et puis peu à peu se
sont s'est imposé 7 cette nécessité qui
participe aussi d'un effort démocratique
ça peut être aussi vu d'un côté positif
le fait de s'informer en permanence de
ceux de ce que veulent les français mais
on connaissait des exemples célèbres de
l'abolition de la peine de mort on en a
reparlé on l'a célébré si françois
mitterrand avait gouverné en fonction
des sondages ils n'auraient pas aboli la
peine de mort donc on voit bien le
danger aussi on voit bien l'écueil de
cette gouvernance par par les sondages
parce que gouverner par les sondages ça
nous rapproche aussi de ce qu'on appelle
la démagogie donc voilà
il ya quand même un équilibre à trouver
et manifestement aujourd'hui on peut se
demander si cette gouvernance par les
sondages ne pollue pas un petit peu le
là je dirais le destin démocratique la
brigitte gates il la gouvernance par les
sondages le sondage boussole d'une
action politique est là on parle pas d'
analyse on parle pas de voilà de notre
travail de l'éditorialiste ou des
journalistes politiques comment vous
réagissez d'une certaine façon
d'ailleurs c'est un peu la même chose
que pour les médias c'est cette
incertitude cette volatilité qui va il
ya une espèce de c'est très difficile
d'agir dans l'incertitude mais quand on
n'arrive pas à maîtriser ce qu'on est en
train de faire est en fait là alors
maîtriser l'action publique maîtrise est
aussi
la compétition électorale parce que
quand vous quand vous mettez des gants
vous élisez en les mettant dans des
listes ces candidats à venir qu'est ce
qui se passe ou pour le voit très bien
la
marine le pen on commence à lui dit un
bon bah peut-être qu'il faut faire
alliance peut-être qu'il faut donc ça
veut dire que ça change complètement
alors même qu'il n'y a eu aucun vote qui
on parle sur une petite proportion de
gens qui ont donné le rejet des eaux
traduit sa chose toutes les stratégies
politiques c'est ça qui en fait en train
de se passer d'un rapprochement éventuel
ans trouvait annie jadot et anne hidalgo
c'est quelque chose d'incroyable
projections même à un petit candidat qui
va se dire je n'atteindrai appel à
barder les 5% donc dans des villages
donc j'ai pas parce que je serai pas
remboursés j'y vais pas jusqu'à pas
remboursés qui vient c'est pas la faute
des sondages de ce point de vue un c'est
vraiment parce que tous les groupements
démocratique se sont un peu effondré les
partis et associations les les
mouvements quel qu'il soit et donc du
coup y'a plus rien d'autre que cette
boussole qui est qui produit des effets
totalement inattendu c'est à dire
vraiment de
sens s éliminé changer les stratégies
faire disparaître quelqu'un d'inconnu
delà de la compétition donc une fois que
c'est fait c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est voilà qui est dans le marbre quoi
donc on peut plus il ya plus de
réversibilité maintien soit votre
conclusion c'est surtout ça tient
lui-même de programme aujourd'hui vous
entendez xavier bertrand son argument
c'est je suis mieux placé la question
qui est posée à eric zemmour au marine
le pen sait qui sera le mieux placé sme
jadot hidalgo exact
on soit on ne fait pas un programme ne
fait pas des idées meerson il devrait
dire je suis le meilleur pour appliquer
mes idées où je vais changer seul
capable de changer la france voilà mais
non c'est le seul argument qu'on entend
là en ce moment dans cette campagne
c'est je suis mieux placé pour battre et
nous vaincrons pour être au second tour
mais moi c'est du hippisme
merci beaucoup on a essayé de prendre un
peu de recul modestement sur cette
frénésie son agir merci à tous et merci
encore jean daniel lévy voilà d'avoir
accepté on va dire un peu de la cuisine
de l'émission au débotté de participer à
ce sens public c'était très sympathique
de de votre part merci mathieu on se
retrouve mer